ben maintenant les choses sont un peu
ENF assez clair en tout cas puisque
monsieur Houlier dit on va détricoter le
texte du Sénat nous
rétablirons le texte de l'ex on va
parler de sa chaolier mais les à l'air
de l'Assemblée est-ce qu'ils vont vous
soutenir non mais le texte va être
détricoté donc nous on va observer d'ici
mais eux à chaque détricotage ils
pointeront du doigt précisément les
abandons et vous êtes sur la même ligne
et on est absolument sur la même ligne
et je dis je vais au-delà vous savez
qu'une loi c'est euh un match en trois
manches il y a le Sénat il y a
l'Assemblée nationale et il y aura une
commission mixte paritaire se députés se
sénateurs parce que il y aura pas
d'accord dans un premier temps entre les
deux chambres croyez-moi si le texte il
est détcoté ce sera
niette